Let's go to our caller from the five oh three
area code.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Five oh three.
Hi, my name is Louise and I'm calling from
Portland, Oregon.
How are you?
How do you do you guys even have phones working
there?
I heard that everything was destroyed.
Oh, I'm.
I'm super sorry.
Yeah, I we we we've been trying to keep it
a secret that that partly was just completely
leveled and raised and.
Yeah.
Just nothing left.
But the vote we got, we still got some bars
up here.
There closed to go.
But although our restaurants are still open
and such which I don't mind bragging a little
bit, the organ is doing pretty well when it
comes to infection rates and things like that.
Well, that may be, but I'm sure I'm sure you
don't have any running water anymore, right?
Oh, absolutely not.
Right.
The running water needed to be used for Biden's
boater under.
Well, of course, of course.
So I do have a.
So my question for you concerns the 13th Amendment
to the United States Constitution, which Section
one reads Neither slavery nor involuntary
servitude, except as a punishment or crime
wire of the parties shall have been duly convicted,
shall exist within the United States or any
place subject to their jurisdiction.
Right.
And my question to you is, does this exception
mean that a form of slavery is still legal
in the United States?
My understanding of that is that if you are
in prison and there is a work requirement
in prison that it would be constitutional.
Now that my my reading may be totally wrong,
but that's my understanding of what that means.
And I believe that you are.
Yeah, I'm with you on that.
And the reason why I see that is that in Oregon,
we had a prison work requirement since 1994.
Right.
Persons convicted.
And as and because of how it's enshrined in
the Constitution.
Prisoners do not have to be paid minimum wage.
Right.
And the work does not have to be safe.
And and I'm also looking at it as both a.
And, of course, you know, California, which
is fighting wildfires, can't pay their convicted
firefighters, shall we say, the two dollars
a day that they've done in the past.
So and that's just scratching the surface,
thank goodness.
So but I just wanted to kind of get a sort
of second opinion on it.
Yeah.
That's my sense of it.
And certainly prison work conditions are a
big topic and something we've dealt with on
the program before.
And hopefully something that when things are
more normal in this country, we can actually
deal with in a sane way.
Yes.
Absolutely.
At all.
I'll keep my eyes peeled for anything changing
on that front.
And of course, if if in Portland, if we rebuild
the city.
No, I'm saying that it just.
Yeah, the.
And as far as and I am hoping that everyone
does stay safe.
We we have some counties in the metro area
approaching evacuation orders for wildfires
and everything else.
So it's a it's a real confluence or conflagration
of emergencies here.
It's an amalgam.
We could even call it Louis from Portland.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you very much, David.
Take it easy.
All right.
You too.
We are going to go to a break